forgiveness is actually valuable or if
we're just tricked into thinking that
kindness compassion and forgiveness is
but it has to come from the people
committing the acts it's only good in
society Trump supporters have done
nothing since Trump got elected if you
only live is like we're only going to
get past this if you apologize you never
again we apologize for yeah what that's
blanket it's for everything they ever
did for what I'm apologizing for
Hillary's crimes before she has to but
you committed a bunch of serious crimes
and continue to wage lawfare against us
while we sit back and do nothing but
we're going to apologize to you this is
how you end up dead this is how
okay oh okay so then just give up
everything I mean what the the way to
end up dead is by suggesting a pardon by
constantly laying down and saying hey
it's okay if you rain piss on us dude
what's your I mean what's the optional
solution then the option is is
the absolute hell out of everyone that
violates your rights